he's not in there for no reason and he
just lights up like
if we had had 10 episodes we had a giant
story line for him
uh built out but he does have plenty of
uh real estate in v6
can i tell you where it's going but yeah
he was great
so i don't know how jurisdiction works
here but i don't have to place you under
arrest
right off the bat we're introduced to a
lot of new characters that are
significant
from different comics what are you
looking forward to
fans seeing in these newcomers i think a
humanity in that we assigned each of the
characters particularly leads
but all of the characters a personal
storyline
meaning a storyline that affects them as
a human being
and not isn't even connected to whether
the bad guys are going to win or not
and by doing that is the blessing of
having a series and by
doing that i believe that these
characters
and these heroes are going to feel
extremely human
uh uh in a way that well in the
in the in the movies they have 10 years
to become fully realized
and we just concentrated into the series
what's terrific
is because we get to know our characters
at a different level i think i'm i'm
pretty sure the fans are really going to
enjoy this ride
because it's full of twists and turns
it's um uh it's everything that
mcu does which is you know the
unexpected expect the unexpected that's
about all
all that you can you know is going to be
true you know it's a it's a fun ride and
the
the action was spectacular we made sure
um
you know the bar was high we had we had
to fit in that emcee
that marvel of it and i think we've
we've really
um you know aimed at we have the same
people we
that make the movies we're doing all the
stuff well you know we're helping us
with
design and stunt work and and so on and
so um
i think we're gonna find that the fans
uh feel like it's a six hour movie
that's that's the goal
is there anyone in the show uh newcomer
otherwise that you felt
closest to or like related to the most i
i don't think you can call
sam a newcomer but obviously his
struggle really resonated with me
and yeah i mean i i can't name
i was almost messed up you almost got me
out
i almost named someone who no one has
talked about so i do want to get into
the first episode a little bit comic
fans will notice pretty quickly in the
first episode that
danny ramirez is somebody significant
and falcon may have a little protege on
his hands
uh what can you tell us about the
possibility of of
the mantle being passed is that who you
were talking about that's what i was
talking about
i forget that you seen the first series
yeah he was great
and and and i can't tell you where it's
going to go
but obviously he's not in there for no
reason and he just lights up like
if we had had 10 episodes we had a giant
storyline for him
uh built out but he does have plenty of
real estate in
can i tell you where it's going but yeah
he was great he's a joy
i mean such a besides talented um
such a a nice young man who has a huge
career ahead of him for sure
and we we found him very early on
um and i think he he's
i guess it's still mission impossible it
has not come out yet so
so i gather he's uh a lovely role in
that so
um i think we're going to be on his uh
we will be on his coattails as he uh
takes off like a like a rocket
um and it's fun to see he and and uh
anthony together
uh and and you know the ref rt that they
have so um
i think the fans are gonna enjoy them i
wanna ask about aaron kellerman
because i've been such a fan of her
since she stole the
show as empty's nest in solo and i can't
wait to see what she
has in store for us do bucky and sam
have any idea what they're up against
with her
no she's amazing and i would argue
that there is how do i say this about
spoilers
to me in a way she's a glue she's the
glue for the series
because what she's able to do
as far as authenticity and humanity
you'll see what i mean
in her storyline if you don't buy her
completely then the seems she has with
other people who we can't name feel
completely fraudulent and what she did
is just ah man she was she i i consider
her to glue to the series
she was lovely to work with um she's a
real
not only a trooper she's a super
talented woman
um and uh and badass is valid and she
worked so hard on her stunts
like all of them spent months working
with the stunt team
and um digging inside uh you know
physicality
it's a very demanding all of these roles
are very demanding physically
in part because um i i said at the
beginning
you know what we're not going to rely on
weapons
so as a result we tried to bring
something new to the
the fight sequences and all that that
that actually weapons aren't really a
part of them so
that that switched it all around so that
now the characters really had to um
uh had to you know fight in a different
way so it was very exciting to see her
embrace that
join me in welcoming your new captain
america
[Music]
[Applause]
then also we have uh wyatt russell
coming into the show is john walker and
we kind of get it we get a glimpse of
him
what's in store for kind of his dynamic
with the existing avengers
he he's awesome i mean you see what
happens with him and
who like he is going he's emerging as
as he's making he's going to have a big
impact on the uh
mcu and he's emerging as a major figure
um um i think the fans are going to be
pretty surprised when they watch that
first episode
uh and see how and and and his evolution
as a character
started off close to the books and then
completely morphed into something very
very
very very different one of my favorite
things in the first episode is
the realization that falcon's like
pretty famous like sam wilson's pretty
famous
how much fun did you have with anthony
mackie and exploring that
it's well it's great and that gets to
the humanity of it like because we had
more time
you get to spend time in a scene like
that in a bank scene
where you're dealing with someone being
famous but maybe being broke and
how do you make your money as a hero and
it's a blast i mean
anthony and sebastian are both able to
play with a given moment
in a way that's electric so you know you
you
half of what you're doing is creating
moments for them to just do what they do
we realize in the first episode too
which i've never like really thought
about that the avengers aren't paid
um i thought that was so funny how do
bucky and sam make a living
it's funny because that scene and that
moment
ended up triggering everybody at marvel
we were getting calls from kevin from
lou
from victoria from nate like everyone in
marvel wanted input there
it's whatever it is about it it has
resonated with the people that have been
interviewing with us
it resonated with everyone working there
so i think i think the reason you keyed
in on it is
you got to see a moment where a
superhero is truly a regular person
and hopefully we answer the question to
some degree that it ain't easy being you
know
a lot of superheroes are broke
especially now that tony stark is gone
oh man well congrats on the show that's
my time but so lovely talking to you and
i can't wait to talk to you
more throughout the series thank you ash
thank you so much
you